Blake Sheldon is back with new music and
it all arrives before the end with 2019
the Oklahoma natives highly anticipated
fully-loaded God's country is set to hit
shelves and streaming services on
December 13th a week and not wait well
it will definitely be a record full of
hits luckily she's already given us a
sneak peek of what fans can expect from
the LP so preparation for the release
breaking down everything we know about
his latest project
they're wicked
[Applause]
the 12 track record will feature seven
of Blake's older hits including only the
dogs turning me on and I lived it
effects own Shore
unless you live
man I live
and for tracks off his 2016 record if
I'm honest including every time I hear
that song
she's got away with words a guy with a
girl and of course came here to forget
[Music]
to
[Music]
now we definitely cannot wait for the
return of some of this older hits but
rounding out the tracklist is five new
songs including Blake's massive hit buds
country which earned him is 14 number
one on Billboard's Hot Country Songs
chart and after winning single veer at
the CMA Awards in 2019 he revealed he
needed a song like God's country to
reignite passion for country music
sometimes I just need you know a song
like God's country to slap me in the
face and go hey man you're you need to
pay attention and get back after this
you know and and that's what it is
Britain by country up-and-comer is Devin
Dawson in the party the song is an ode
the land that Blake loves the most is
hometown in Oklahoma this is brought to
life neat powerful music video
[Music]
this is
[Music]
joining God's country is Blakes current
hit hell right is routing a duet with
the one and only Trace Adkins
[Music]
and the new faith inspired reflective
tract called Jesus got a tight grip
Jesus got it
[Music]
the geezers got
the complete tracklist features two more
new songs along with the three recent
singles we cannot wait to hear nobody
but you and tequila Sheila Blake will be
bringing these new songs and the fewest
closest buddies on the road for the
extension of his friends and heroes tour
they'll be joined by special guest
Lauren Alaina as well as appearances by
the Bellamy Brothers John Anderson and
Trace Adkins on a 16 date run that kicks
off in 2020 it is safe to say all these
teachers have made us even more excited
for the arrival of we loaded God's
country so what do you think of the
album's so far let us know in the
comments below
[Music]